kidsmas are like you you were nominated
for Teacher of the Year when you yes I
was good you know
yes I've told this story many times
teacher of the year is a very
prestigious award has taken very
seriously and rightly by the
hard-working teaching community and my
head teacher called me in and he was
wetting himself laughing it's people
stop laughing for the first 10 minutes
and he went I mean what why have you
called me here he goes ok it was by a
very sweet girl called jammer I've
humiliated many times and it's a six
page document that people have to fill
in for the reasons why you should be
nominated Teacher of the Year it was
blank aside from one sentence that she'd
written on it which was of the reasons
why you think he should be Teacher of
the Year and she'd written he's a well
good laugh and he don't make us do no
work
[Applause]
[Music]
five years late and you forget
[Applause]
and I was trying to have a penis service
and she then she banged on the door it
come on